>> Will Sentance: Ai có thể đề xuất một cách tốt hơn
so với việc có các bản sao của từng chức năng trên mỗi người dùng?
Nhưng nhớ lại tôi vẫn muốn có thể làm được điều này.
Chà, hãy giữ suy nghĩ đó một chút.
Ai đó có thể nghĩ ra một cách tốt hơn?
Jeff, bạn có một nụ cười gượng gạo, bạn muốn.
>> Jeff: Chà, bạn có thể sử dụng một dự án tạo ra một nguyên mẫu.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, có thể là Kelly, bạn sẽ có một suy nghĩ trực giác có thể
chúng tôi làm thay vì có các bản sao của tất cả các chức năng của chúng tôi trên mỗi đối tượng?
Chúng ta có thể làm gì, theo một nghĩa rất đơn giản, Todd?
>> Todd: Chà, tôi chỉ có một người dùng chính mà chúng ta có thể tham khảo từng người.
>> Will Sentance: Gần, rất, rất trực quan và đơn giản, Braydon?
>> Braydon: Tạo các hàm chấp nhận đối tượng bạn đang sử dụng.
>> Will Sentance: Đó là một cách khác, nhưng vấn đề với điều đó sau đó,
sau đó chúng ta rơi trở lại thế giới cũ của chức năng của tôi ở đâu?
Tôi có thể áp dụng nó cho bất cứ điều gì.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi muốn chúng được nhóm theo cùng một cách, đúng không, Matt?
>> Matt: Chỉ cần thêm một chức năng.
>> Will Sentance: Chỉ cần thêm một hàm trong một đối tượng và
bằng cách nào đó JavaScript biết rằng khi nó
không tìm thấy gia tăng trên user2, không bỏ cuộc.
Chúng tôi không có chức năng gia tăng trên user2.
Không có chức năng gia tăng trên user1, nhưng
một đối tượng duy nhất, >> Will Sentance: We
có thể gọi nó, tôi không biết, cửa hàng chức năng.
Chúng tôi sẽ sử dụng một chức năng, vì vậy tôi không biết, và
trong đó có chức năng gia tăng của chúng tôi.
Và bằng cách nào đó, hy vọng rằng JavaScript có một số tính năng
điều đó có nghĩa là khi nó không tìm thấy.
Nó truy cập user2, tìm kiếm bộ nhớ, tìm kiếm thuộc tính gia tăng trên nó,
không tìm thấy, không hoảng sợ, không bỏ cuộc, nhưng bằng cách nào đó biết đi và
tìm hàm trong đối tượng này, lấy mã của nó và chạy nó.
Và đó chính xác là những gì JavaScript sẽ làm.
Chuỗi nguyên mẫu, chúng tôi sẽ lưu trữ hàm gia tăng chỉ trong một đối tượng.
Và nhờ JavaScript giải thích nó.
Đó là phần nhìn vào nó và tôi phải làm gì với điều đó?
Từ này có nghĩa là gì?
Trong khi tôi đi tìm kiếm điều đó.
Có nó, nếu nó không tìm thấy chức năng trên user1 hoặc trong trường hợp này là user2,
không bỏ cuộc, nhưng bằng cách nào đó hãy tìm kiếm đối tượng đó, tìm số gia tăng và sử dụng nó.
Chúng tôi phải liên kết user1 hoặc user2 và đối tượng lưu trữ hàm này mà tôi đã tạo.
Vì vậy, trình thông dịch, chúng tôi không tìm thấy sự gia tăng,
đảm bảo kiểm tra đến cửa hàng chức năng, nơi nó sẽ tìm thấy nó.
Và chính xác như Jeff đã gợi ý, hãy tạo liên kết đó bằng kỹ thuật object.create.
Đây là con người.
Hãy xem, các chức năng do người dùng tạo thay đổi như thế nào, chúng tôi vẫn đang tạo ra người dùng mới.
Nhưng bây giờ chúng ta đang sử dụng kỹ thuật object.create để tạo đối tượng,
và nhìn vào cái này.
Nó vẫn sẽ là một vật thể trống rỗng.
Nhưng tôi có cảm giác rằng thực tế là chúng ta đang chuyển vào cửa hàng chức năng của người dùng,
chúng tôi sẽ gọi nó là cửa hàng chức năng người dùng,
mà nhìn bề ngoài nó là một đối tượng lớn hơn ở đây với hai chức năng.
Tôi đã thêm một cái khác, gia tăng và đăng nhập.
Và bằng cách nào đó tôi sẽ có một liên kết đằng sau hậu trường về đối tượng này.
Sẽ không có chức năng gia tăng.
Sẽ không có chức năng tăng dần trên đó.
Có ai thấy tôi thêm một hàm tăng vào đối tượng người dùng mới không?
Tôi không thấy.
Nhưng bằng cách nào đó, nó sẽ có một liên kết đến các chức năng lưu trữ được chia sẻ.
Có nghĩa là khi chúng tôi trả lại đối tượng,
liên kết đó sẽ vẫn là các chức năng của cửa hàng được chia sẻ.
>> Will Sentance: Nó sẽ rất, rất tốt.
Nhân tiện,
cách tiếp cận này về cơ bản sẽ đạt được tất cả những điều chúng ta muốn đạt được.
Bên cạnh thực tế là nó sẽ liên quan đến một chút viết mã.
Và có thể có một số cách viết tắt để đạt được điều này.
Và giải pháp ba và
bốn sẽ chỉ là những cách rút gọn để thực hiện điều này.
Đây là cốt lõi tuyệt đối.